welcome back to me rock stars I'm Eric
Voss and spider-man is officially back
in the MCU with an announcement from
both Disney and Sony declaring that
they've worked out a deal for at least
two more Tom Holland spider-man films to
follow up too far from home planned for
July 2021 and a future MCU film that
Peter Parker will appear in this is
indisputably great news there's a lot to
break down here we're gonna be
discussing various aspects of it in
several upcoming videos including was
this just a hoax by both sides to play
the fans like I feel a bit plain happy
but played anyway according to sources
one major factor that weighed very
heavily on these negotiations was the
specific way far from home ended and at
least part of what they're referring to
is probably the return of JK Simmons
it's Jay jonah Jameson who helped
Mysterio out Peter Parker make him a
public menace
Simmons Jameson was the editor of The
Daily Bugle from Sam Raimi spider-man
films and now he looks like an info war
style conspiracy theorist that kind the
friggin frogs gay just recently they
have released an entire Daily Bugle
dotnet promotional site with bonus video
footage of Jay jonah Jameson and looking
through this thing you can actually find
some clues to start to put together
where future spider-man movies might be
headed like what kind of villain could
Jameson be for Peter Parker how does
this connect to the venom storyline I am
going to explain how this blowhard
newscaster will play the pivotal role in
spider-man's future it's more a warning
the case setting my theories or
speculation and being too accurate ok
let's start by digging into this goofy
Daily Bugle Nets site it's mostly a
parody of any lame graphics news side
there's an extended article about night
monkey that quotes Ned Leeds who
awkwardly tries to explain who is on a
spot euro spider-man incarnation is
there's also an article about Mysterio's
water monster protection that describes
it as Hydra man entices to Morris bench
and secret hydro generator experiments
by the Navy this is actually hydro man
Mori benches origin in the spider-man
comics and it ties in with what the
students read about the monster and far
from home
BuzzFeed says there's a sailor named
Morris Ben she was exposed to
experimental underwater generator and
got Hydra powers yeah you should
definitely believe everything you read
on the Internet there's another report
about spider-man's take down to the
Manfredi crime family
referring to the deleted sequence from
the far from home extended cut that
showed Peter Parker fighting the man
Freddy's aka Silvio Manfredi Silvermane
from the spider-man comics and on the
main page
there's this video clip from Jameson
himself spider-man a psychopath wielding
powers he has no right to possess trying
to pass himself off as a hero well let
me tell you something kid
you're no hero Mysterio that's a hero
you are a criminal okay few things here
first you gotta love that whole cocaine
nod from Jameson well let me tell you
something kid bro let me tell you
something brother second the image that
he shows a Mysterio is the worst
possible shot to show of him if you want
him to look legit his legs are cut off
like one of the drone projectors that
create this illusion must have been
damaged or not rendering the image
properly this is clearly a projection
also it's interesting that Jameson does
not go the furthest step that Quentin
Beck did in the clip Jamison showed in
the part from home post-credits scene
which docks to Peter Parker and revealed
his name and face now maybe this Daily
Bugle clip was taped before Quentin Beck
died and released the video the docs
Peter
either way this suggests that Mysterio's
ongoing media manipulation could
continue to be the primary threat for
Peter in the next spider-man film
Quentin Beck may be dead or he may not
be but t Mysterio as a unit lives on and
with Jameson as their primary media
trumpet or bugle Mysterio can become
even more powerful as a shadow
organization designed to erode public
support of superheroes and Harold's
villains as the ones we should trust and
support with our money and our votes now
there are a few other details to point
out from the site there's a humorous
blip blog with an entry for mr.
Harrington talking about how his wife
used the blip to fake her death and
leave him which he talked about in the
movie also an interesting post from a
stuntman who injured himself during the
fall because the landing pad was moved
during the five-year gap now technically
that contradicts the rules of the blip
because the avengers in-game filmmakers
have explained that Hulk's nap was more
of a wish to bring everyone back safely
so like people who were in airplanes the
moment of the snap wouldn't return
midair they just returned to the nearest
safe spot though you know tell that to
that marchi man player who got tackled
and far from home
anyway the potentially biggest detail
comes in a post that seems completely
throwaway a joke post about the recent
area 51 raid Jameson rants about the
real aliens who do exist referring to
the alien tech that damages city in the
Battle of New York but there's an even
deeper truth to Jameson's anger here
that could set up the plot for the next
spider-man movie before we continue
thank you to dashlane for sponsoring
this episode
- lanes safely stores all your passwords
in one place and auto fills them so that
you don't need to remember like 20
different random strings of letters
numbers and symbols that you know you're
just trying to make the word password
look different - Lloyd's desktop and
mobile app is a full suite of tools all
in one package including a password
manager autofill for personal info and
payment details and a password generator
so you don't have to try to think of
them yourself look the dark times of
deceitful media sources invasion of
privacy and misuse of personal
information isn't just the reality of
Peter Parker's world it's also the world
we live in
I haven't had my superhero identity
revealed yet but I have had my loser
youtuber I didn't be stolen and social
media accounts hacked and I can tell you
it is just as bad so that's why services
like dashlane are so useful
- lain securely saves and autofills all
your passwords login info as well as
addresses phone numbers credit cards so
you never have to click forgot password
again or even worse write it down on a
notepad by your computer and then take a
selfie video there and then shady folks
see you post that and it ruins your life
- Lee and also offers a dark web
monitoring alerting you if your personal
info is found leaked on the dark web /
spammers and hackers to use so that you
don't have to go in the dark web
yourself and then the XLE end up on a
lot of weird mailing lists download
dashlane for free using our link in the
description - Lane comm slash new rock
stars or use the promo code new rock
stars okay back to Jay jonah Jameson's
paranoia and hatred and
extraterrestrials if you remember in
last year's venom film the host
symbiotes crash-landed with light
foundation astronauts one of whom had a
very important name one of the
astronauts is still alive yes astronaut
John Jameson is in the spider-man comics
and in the venom film the son of Jay
jonah Jameson and historically the
astronaut who pilots the spacecraft
connected with the Venom symbiote
survival to earth so in that venom
opening sequence John Jameson briefly
serves as a host to the riot symbiote
before riot jumps to a Malaysian EMT and
causes the ambulance to crash presumably
John Jameson
not survive crash looks pretty nasty
definitely wasn't buckled in and pretty
much all other human hosts died after
symbiote possession so that makes Daily
Bugle dotnet host Jay jonah Jameson a
grieving father and the light foundation
covered up that entire scandal of course
Jameson would use his media skills to
launch the two wild conspiracy theories
about the danger of aliens and
government cover-ups because in his eyes
that's not a conspiracy theory it's real
and it took his son from him but this
universe has another media investigator
I'm Eddie Brock and this is the Brock
Report yeah by the end of venom Brock
decides to return to his career as the
world's coolest journalist
so the third spider-man film the
follow-up too far from home is coming
July 2021 and while it will be once
again connected to them see you as a
joint Sony production this could also be
a world in which venom characters join
Peter so what if Eddie Brock's
association with the same alien symbiote
race that killed John Jameson makes
Brock a target for J jonah Jameson
Brock's role as a disciplined print
journalist would probably make him a bit
frustrated with the online conspiracy
ranter of J John Jameson perhaps enough
to even make him sympathetic to
Jameson's primary punching bag
spider-man Peter Parker this could be
how spider-man and venom team-up Eddie
Brock using hard-hitting journalism to
expose a shadow network of team Mysterio
and Jay jonah Jameson and clear Peters
name and spider-man fighting alongside
venom to fight an even worse threat
carnage with Woody Harrelson as the
serial killer Cletus Kasady set up in
the venom post-credits scene do you
think spider-man's next movie will be a
venom crossover or should spider-man 3
have a different focus like the sinister
six Kraven the hunter comment down below
with your thoughts follow me on
instagram and twitter at EA boss'd
and actually you know it's sign out for
a May Triple J thanks for watching don't
forget to Like and subscribe
[Music]